về tình yêu giữa dòng người chơi khác nụ cười ấy vẫn ướt ở đây không ạ
anh alo chào các bạn ạ
ừ ừ
em tắt Sao tự nhiên có tiếng ting ting nhớ từ bên mình đúng không ạ
à à
ừ ừ
Xin chào bạn ở
đây để mình ghi lại
mình sẽ quay ngẫu nhiên các nhóm được bảo vệ
đợt một
nhóm nào muốn được bảo vệ thì tốt hơn nhé
à à ờ ờ các bạn chuẩn bị xét xử chưa Chuẩn
bị tinh thần chưa
em có danh sách hôm trước rồi đúng không còn cảnh sát rồi
ờ ờ
Ừ để xem thủ được mùa thì có bao nhiêu
nhiều nhé
à à
khi Đắp mộ chả có tác ma xe tải copy là em
em copy cái số nhóm cái này
rồi nên Alo mày - 2 cái Ngó hôm trước đúng không phải nó như trước được bảo vệ
rồi chặt bỏ qua
Ừ anh sẽ cho nhóm 21 nữa là nhóm 31 này à
chị sẽ có trong giờ bao nhiêu năm nữa luôn
3 cách để xem nhanh có dễ thường mà mình sẽ mở sạc cái tách lên mình xem xuống
dòng ngày có 12 14 nhóm 14 nhóm trung bình mỗi nhóm thì sẽ được bảo vệ trong
vòng 15 phút ờ ờ
chị sẽ được bảo vệ thuyết trình các từ trong 15 phút thuyết trình ấy còn là
phản biện thì không giới hạn thời gian toàn điện Khe hỏi Chán chán thì thôi
à Hôm nay tôi đặc cách cho hai nhóm kia được miễn thôi nhé Còn còn hôm sau thì
tặng sẽ chưa biết rồi đó Nói chung mà Giả sử một cái buổi bảo vệ này tôi nghĩ
là phải tầm 2 tiếng mỗi mỗi tiếng 4 nhóm
đi chậm như thế 8 nhóm à Nghĩa là một buổi 8 nhóm Thế hai buổi là hợp lý rồi
nghĩa đối ngoại dư dả thời gian 14 nhóm mà thở ra luôn nhé
Á đù đù
số 1đầu đây [âm nhạc]
mọi người nghe tiếng chó Không không không phải em cũng được à
anh ạ
à à
à à Anh quay lén đun cái gì Nhóm 1 lại nhóm
đầu tiên này không tôi tôi mới chỉ đang thử đâu nhé
Tớ chưa làm thật được tí sẽ quay thật sao nha Thì sẽ game này hi vọng nhóm 10
phải ngó mụn nữa à
khi nhớ quay tôi chỉ qua một lần rồi đấy Tôi sẽ chỉ qua một lần sau đó thì sẽ ở
sẽ theo đúng với danh sách đấy đúng thứ tự đấy trong buổi hôm nay buổi trong
buổi hôm nay thôi còn buổi sau lại quay lại không ạ ạ
ờ ờ bé tranh thủ tâm sự một tí nhỉ
anh ở đây à à à
ở bên này có cái tâm sự này em
có cái chào mọi người không biết là cái phục vụ mình thỉnh thoảng mình cập nhật
Cái này các bạn để ý mô tả các dụng phụ nghiêm trọng ờ
Ừ tự nhiên mình mình ngại ghi cái tâm sự gì thì có cái thiếu sự linh cảm đây
Cái này là một câu mà đã từng có một người từng nói mình về với mình rất là
lâu rồi khi
đóng một buổi hôm sau sẽ loại bỏ những nhóm bảo vệ rồi này chứ Đúng rồi à
có cây cây cây về khái niệm này Thực ra mình mình là mình tự nói với bản thân
mình thôi nó cũng chẳng hạn ở liên quan đến dân không hẳn liên quan đến công
nghệ lắng nhưng mà cái cái cái này Đầu tiên là
Ừ cái tôi tôi thật ra tôi biết được rõ là tôi
bị cái xuống tình cảm này là không Nếu mà ai chưa biết có khái niệm này nó kiểu
họ nó còn có thể gây ra là kẹp tăm bệnh được rồi được trao trả con bận cũng bệnh
Nó tên là ai ký vậy ai cái gì đấy à A Gọi ác tình đâu hai kỳ gì nhỉ Anh chỉ
cực đoan không không Ừ cái gì nhỉ
à À không phải luyến ái hai kỳ quyền sử mới rồi
đợi thích người bạn thân đi à
a loạn liên kết cái kia Hình như thế hình như thế
A Gọi Hình như thế này ờ
à à Ừ cái này là tự cao này
vì thiếu sự đồng cảm này à Ừ
đúng rồi
Cái này là tôi đọc nó nguyên nhân đấy nó do là hồi bé bị thiếu thốn tình cảm nên
là lúc nào mong được công nhận kiểu cửa thế này giờ và lớn lên nó kêu dạng là
lúc nào cũng cũng mong được thừa nhận cái này Thực ra là có cái điểm
cái gì nó sẽ có 2 mặt của nó ưu và nhược ngoạn cái này ngược thì các bạn thấy rồi
nó là tự cao này hồi trưa tôi có kiểu tự cao hiểu đôi khi
khó nói chuyện người khác hiểu thôi sinh người và thiếu sự đồng cảm đến bây giờ
được ra tốt vẫn thiếu số thiếu sự đồng cảm thôi Thực ra là
tôi cố lòng cảm thấy khác đấy Nhưng mà thực ra cũng nhiều lúc hơi vô tâm thật
kiểu giống như là tôi một cốc cả ngày chẳng đi xung quanh Như nào chẳng hạn
thế đã cả là thế đó tôi không hả nở Nhớ lắm
Bây giờ tôi không bị ơi mẹ tôi không bị cái bệnh này nặng lắm nhưng mà
tôi trộm sửa được khá nhiều đấy chứ so với hồi trước hiện tại thì hiện tại thì
có vài ông vẫn có vẻ Đang quý tôi ý nhở như thế Hồi xưa chẳng ai quý rồi tôi
hàng như thế Bây giờ ít bạn lắm cách nói chuyện tôi đúng kiểu khinh Huyện Cái Tôi
đã sửa được khá nhiều vụ đấy rồi nhưng mà cài lưu cái này thì thì như các bạn
thấy đó là kiểu Mong được thừa nhận ông ạ mong được sự công nhận mong được cá
ngợi và Vân Tức là chỉ là con người Kiểu như này thì ạ Họ sẽ cố giỏi hết sức có
thể chứ phải cố Cố kiểu kém nhất có thể chẳng ai công nhận cả đúng ngon họ sẽ cố
giỏi nhớ thể thực ra là có khá nhiều danh nhân rồi không phải cá
nhân là tiếng nói chung khá nhiều người nổi tiếng bị bị cái này
em có đi nhá tôi thực kể ra nha nó là chị lâu này thì nó bị cái này luôn bị
nặng luôn tự cao Xong hồi sinh người nhưng mà nhưng mà họ mua khi có tải Tôi
đang nói Khái niệm và mục khi Ở họ có tài thực ra là tôi không biết mấy ông
nghĩ thế nào về cái việc à về cái chế độ phát xít nhưng mà chuẩn
chế độ phát xít nó có điểm rất là tốt khi mà chẳng phải nghe theo đám đông
ngồi mỗi đám đông thì mỗi lần một tí mỗi người một ý thì đôi khi ở sẽ không
làm được việc gì lớn còn nếu mà Giả sử một người mà người đấy có suy nghĩ tầm
tầm nhìn lớn và đúng đúng ý anh Thắng 82 có một mình mình làm thì đôi khi nó lại
đi lên nhớ đương nhiên là nếu mà việc không nghe ai cả thì khi mình sai thì
mình sai rất lớn đúng không ạ Đấy thì
cho tôi tôi nói là Cái bệnh này thường gặp giúp được tôi được như bây giờ con
người thôi Được như bây giờ cũng chắc là cũng nhờ cái bệnh này bởi vì thực sự là
tôi vẫn muốn mình khác biệt muốn mình được được cái gì đó cài
anh nói chung là có cái tôi mà đúng không lạnh ra là cũng ít nhiều giúp mình
phấn đấu nhưng mà ngược thì cái gì có cái Ưu nhược đúng không Các bạn thấy nó
sẽ cậu người những người ấy sẽ ít bạn này và thiếu sự đồng cảm Nói chung là
cũng khá mệt Khi cái tôi đang muốn nói ở đây không phải nói về cá nhân tôi trong
dịp này mà nó là về về thứ hai tôi muốn nói Đó là các bạn phải nhìn nhận vào bản
thân mình là mình Ừ không hẳn là mình bị một cái bệnh gì
mà làm Mình có ở điểm gì yếu điểm thủy mạnh và cái đấy nó sẽ có lợi ở trong
trường hợp nào thì mình tận dụng nó giống như nghề nghiệp luôn cũng thế đã
sử tôi chọn đừng nề này Thậm chí tôi chọn được khá nhiều nghề Bởi vì tôi có
kiểu thích nó ấy này thì tôi Thậm chí tôi làm luật sự được thì tôi giỏi cãi
thôi rọi tranh luận à ở
đây tôi thể chọn được khá nhiều ngành nghề một kìa cái tính cách của tôi là
thế thì mấy ông phải nhìn nhận được bản thân mình có điểm mạnh điểm yếu là gì để
chọn cho dù kể cả ngành Công nghệ thông tin này các bạn lỡ trọng rồi bạn làm
theo rồi ra là nó về sau nó vẫn thể dạy nhảy nó rất nhiều cái không phải mình về
sau mình vẫn cắm mặt vào cốt được đây sau mình có thể làm nên làm quản lý hoặc
là nên vẫn chỉ ngồi cốt nghĩa là sự mình không muốn nói chuyện với ai cả thì mình
sẽ quản lý đội tách chứ không phải còn lý nội vận hành Hải Vân có rất nhiều
hướng mà các bạn có thể hình dung được là một công ty vẫn là ngành công nghệ
thông tin mà thể rất nhiều có phải biến điểm yếu thành điểm mạnh
chứ anh người Hồi trước tôi đọc được ở đâu Nó bảo là người mạnh không phải là
người không có niềm yếu người ta người mẹ nhẹ vào người phải biết tận dụng điểm
yếu mình hàng cái điểm mạnh thì nó mới ở người mặn nghĩa là sao Nghĩa là điểm yếu
của tôi là sự tôi mà Thắng nói nhiều này thì tôi sẽ chọn những cái cái gì đó mà
người ta sẽ không khó chịu thì tao nói nhiều ví dụ ở dạy học Nga đã Ngạn chẳng
ai bảo đã thầy nói ít thôi để ý nhờ đi thôi đúng không Thì
Ê mấy ông phải vận dụng điều đấy nhưng mà đương nhiên cũng phải khắc phục nó
bằng cách ông phải nói những cái thứ Người ta muốn nghe chứ phải nói than
Thiên thì thì khi khác nói nhiều càng sai ông ạ
Đấy thì mấy ông chỉ cần khắc phục để hiểu đấy bao nhiêu bảo mẹ thành công
đúng ạ ạ wa phải biến ngược thành lưu thì đấy
mới làm con người kiểu thứ nhất là phải biết nhìn nhận bản thân cái sai cái câu
là biết mình biết ta trăm trận biết địch biết ta đúng không trăm trận trăm thắng
đúng không Thì cái biết ta ở đây là gì là biết bản thân mình đang đang như thế
nào đúng không để mà cậu xem có xem có cần phải sửa thì không không ạ
khi đôi khi mấy ông đôi khi đi phỏng vấn ấy thì mấy ông à
Ừ thứ nhất ở chưa tìm hiểu được các công ty đấy có những cái gì có những điểm
mạnh điểm yếu gì kêu trời chỉ mong có được việc làm tốt lắm thôi nhưng hàng ra
là béo lại không chịu tìm hiểu công ty ở như nào phù hợp Minh không hàng ra ở
kiểu đi phỏng vấn đối không Thứ hai là mấy cũng không biết điểm yếu để mạnh của
mình là cái gì để khi phỏng vấn đề ra thứ họ một câu cái kiểu cứ điểm lớn nhất
của em là gì Nếu trả lời đâu Mở hộp cần
em có thấy mạng gì so với người khác sao rồi ứng cử viên cũng trả lời được
cho tôi tôi trả lời được đấy ví dụ của sử tôi không Mày nói tôi nói nhiều nữa
tôi sẽ nói là tôi Perry năng tối thể cái gì có thể nhảy vào làm được
tay nhưng nó vẫn tự tin hơn đánh cá về hàng khác nó đang không tự tin nó đang
bước bước chân nó còn là giun thì chắc chả non mình tự tin mình cắm đầu chạy
em có khi ở vẫn nhanh hơn nó sao rồi kể cả nó thằng chạy nhanh hơn mình nhưng mà
nó còn đang run Mình cắm đầu chạy trước rồi biết đâu Mình đã thảm đúng không
những người cả đời này chưa có thể chạy sai đường ấy ra mình đã chạy còn hơn
thằng này đứng ở chỗ đúng không Nếu mình chạy đúng thì mình ăn được ăn cả ngã vì
không
đấy Đấy Hạ qua hai cái này thôi muốn lại muốn nói thêm các bạn nói cho một cái
thứ mà tôi hướng đến không phải tôi dạy cho các bạn Mỗi nghề mà tôi muốn hướng
đến các bạn một cái vài góc nhìn gì gì đó Bởi vì cái tầm tuổi các bạn thực ra
là hại từng trải ai từng trải qua thôi tầm tuổi mà các bạn vẫn còn đang mông
lung Nhưng mà trò đùa về tương lai cấp 3 này hay ở đại học năm nhất năm hai còn
cả ông ông nào đang mất ngồi đây để mặc một nghe tôi chém gió thì chắc là tí
thôi nghe nhạc thì ít thôi anh ạ
à à
đi chậm mà chắc à Làm gì có chuyện chắc ở đấy ông ông đang nắm nhận năm nhất năm
hai ông không chắc chắn một cái gì vậy Kể cả việc anh mãi mãi yêu em rồi phải
tự đọc lại các bạn không chắc một cái gì ở đây cả ông 20 tuổi ông chắc được cái
gì thằng có gì Trả lời cả kể cả các gia
đình ông 1 tỷ phú nữa không Chắc là sau ôm vẫn sẽ là tỷ phú
anh Đúng không
20 tuổi có không chắc là một cái gì cả Không chỉ cắm đầu vào chạy sai thì ngã
đâu mất dạy ở đấy không phải gấp đôi ở đấy đâu nhé
đi ông phải đi còn chậm thế Và sẽ có đầy ạ và đầy đứa tầm tuổi ông là không dám
đi thì cái việc Ông dám đi thay vì nó không dám đi thì ông ăn nó rồi ông ăn
được phần đông ấy rồi trừ những thằng con nhà người ta nó nó biết được đường
đúng nó cắm đầu đi và nó đi bằng bằng cái gì đó thì thì ông không ăn được nó
rồi còn bây giờ ông chắc chắn ông sẽ ăn được những cái hàng mà nó không dám đi
đúng không ạ Bây giờ ông còn ngồi đấy tính đã ông ông ông chưa chắc đã có gì
trong tay bằng mấy cái thằng nhà giàu Sẵn đâu đấy Hàng nhà gió sẵn nó còn có
cái gì à Còn có dự phòng vợ có cửa hậu nó còn có đô dù nó đi nó đi đâu được nó
vẫn có ô dù mình nó không đi đám tay cả thì chỉ mình cũng chẳng có gì để mất cả
cái mình cứ thế mà đi thôi Đúng không mấy ông sợ mất gì việc mà Mấy ông ngồi ở
nhà không nghĩ cái thứ không mất thời gian hơn những vừa cắm đầu đi mình sẽ
nghiện
bài hát một hai năm nữa chưa sắt biết ở đâu Mấy ông vậy cứ đến đến tầm tuổi tôi
tôi bằng khẳng định không có gì chắc chắn không thể ổn định cái câu khái niệm
mà sự nghiệp ổn định ấy nó bìa trong cái ngày mai là người thứ rất là mô Hồ luôn
Không có gì ổn định đây cả ông có thể bay lên và hạ xuống cái rất nhanh trong
cái ngày này Đấy riêng ngành này có ngành khác đó
không biết có nhiều ngày nghỉ ngồi văn phòng ở bệnh viện nhà nước đấy Đúng an
phận thật lúc đầu kiếm cái ghê rồi cứ ngồi đợi đấy nhưng mà còn ngành này học
một vài ngày nữa ví dụ giống như dịch vừa rồi bùng phát kể cả nhà ông có cửa
hàng mấy cái cửa hàng to bùng phát Ông có thể phá sản thế thằng có gì ở ổn định
một cái chắn ở đây rồi ông chỉ có dám làm hay không hơn thằng khác ở cái chí
rồi đúng không anh nói chung nhà giống như tôi bảo ông
không có gì trong tay không Không việc gì mất cả ông mất lỗi thời gian nhưng bù
lại ông sẽ có kinh nghiệm đúng không ạ ừ ừ
ừ ừ
anh không Yêu cầu sinh viên năm của thế Quan
trọng gì về cái việc sinh viên cái người kia bao nhiêu tuổi đâu Mấy cái học cấp 3
đôi khi vẫn được mà nên là bây giờ họ đang bỏ dần khái niệm là xinh viện phải
yêu cầu bằng cấp 2 yêu cầu ở sinh đang học năm bao nhiêu rồi Thậm chí còn yêu
bỏ và yêu cầu đang học trường nào rồi Có vài gì đi mình có thấy ở còn yêu cầu đã
học trường gì nhưng thực ra là nó vẫn không ăn trộm đâu các bạn chỉ cần khoe
các bạn từng làm cái gì đó là được thôi à à
anh làm sao quản lý thời gian tốt Tôi không
phải một con người quản lý thời gian tốt với thực ra tôi cắm mắt ngày đêm được
làm một cái thứ gì đó mất ăn mất ngủ nên là tôi khó mà khuyên ông được cái vụ này
nhưng để nói việc à Ông làm tốt hay không ấy chỉ đơn giản không cắt thời
gian khác phải làm đi cắt mọi thử sao Nhã này làm đi Một là ông có động lực để
làm có người làm cùng là hai loại chị đấy tôi bảo Hồi trưa tôi kiếm sư cùng
yêu thương rồi lúc đấy kiểu dạng cảm thấy hiểu tôi vào
tối xu hướng tình cảm tôi nói rồi tôi lúc nào cũng cần có người ở bên hãy ra
khi có người ở bên rồi Tôi tập trung làm mọi việc hơn nhưng mà như là vì tôi là
đôi khi ông có người ngồi có cùng chí hướng cùng không Em cần phải người yêu
rủ thằng bạn thân cùng phấn đấu đảm ạ Mỗi cũng làm được mà
khi hai người có trận thứ hai công ty càng tốt đừng nên cùng công ty cùng công
ty đâu chị ạ Không hẳn là giúp là nhau nhiều đâu khác công ty xong rồi nhưng mà
vẫn ngồi cốt cùng vẫn đi cà phê cốt cùng nhau sử
khi tìm được không Sao ạ Ừ nhưng mà tôi bảo đấy thì để làm tốt
với cái gì đó thì ông phải cắt quãng thời gian khác đi nhưng mọi khi là điều
ông ngủ 8 tiếng thì Xuka là khi mà cũng đã cày ngày đêm ông không để thời gian
ngủ đó
à à
Ở đây có muôn thuở mà còn nên phải học Đại học hay không thì cái này thì mình
từng trả lời rồi đấy sao bạn phải xem những video trước thôi họ là trao Google
ra nhiều lắm em làm áp phải làm web có gì khác nhau
không Chắc là chủ yếu ở ngôn ngữ rồi còn về tư duy tư duy là gần như nó giống
nhau đứng ở nó sẽ khác nhau vài cái kiểu dặm như ở với web thì thì không phải
ngôn ngữ nữa mà nên dùng Cơ chế này rồi có chuyện kia phải biết ở Cơ chế này có
chuyện kia áp những thế nhưng mà về Nói chung thì làm phần mềm lập trình thì đều
là theo nguyên tắc là kiểu xử lý nó giống nhau mà
Ba tháng Tư nhé Ê thằng tháng tư bắt đầu sang Nga
làm đồ án nâng cao còn tháng bài sẽ học học khóa nâng cao nhưng mà kiểu dân gian
dân ý ừ ừ
cô bạn kia hỏi tôi về cái mình cái Tôi không biết Tôi cũng không rõ cơ hội nghị
bằng việc làm nhiều không nhưng mà C với sự cộng thì ra tội từng nói qua đó là
kiểu nó yêu cầu năm kinh nghiệm nên là các bạn mà bây
giờ mới bắt đầu đâm đầu đấy thì không nên các bạn nên làm những cái mà cậu
những cái ngôn ngữ giờ vẫn còn đang phổ biến TP là ra vitour xây xát à
vài cái nữa nó không yêu cầu năm kinh nghiệm gia Swift nó không cầu năm kinh
nghiệm chỉ còn những cái cũ cũ người yêu cầu cũng năm kinh nghiệm thì các bạn bây
giờ mới nhảy vào được không Không được đâu
Ừ thôi bây giờ bắt đầu chạy ngẫu nhiên à anh sẵn sàng chưa
trại ngẫu nhiên rồi tôi tạo dùm rồi À nhầm tạo mít rồi
cho anh nhìn vào thôi nhóm 6 356
có lần cuối nhớ tôi chưa chấm cho nhóm này về cái á
Ừ thế tài liệu không biết được chưa Ừ ok nhóm 6 bắt đầu thôi à
ở nhóm này là nhóm có Hưng và nhất hoàn
Vì Sao mặt buồn mày để bảo vệ thử mà ông
hãy mong là được bảo vệ thôi chứ không bảo vệ thật mà cũng chưa được bảo bạch
thử phải không chết nữa đúng không ạ à à
cách làm xôi mà thôi thì các bạn chuẩn bị mic cá thử nha
ừ ừ ở đâu rồi à
ừ ừ
à nho nhọn
ờ ờ ờ nhóm tiếp theo nhóm 32 và nhóm 13 nhá
Mình nhầm để em chuẩn bị dần thì đúng không ạ
à à A
Happy ở đây chưa ạ Ê
thằng được mấy ông vào Thích thì vào ngay kẹp được Nếu không đừng có giấy tím
đậm hồn là được thôi sẽ mút mấy ông ấy à
ừ ừ
anh em hôm kia nha Bị hôm nay không ạ Không bảo vệ được
Khi nào mày đâu có mới có một thành viên đúng không Hay là mấy mấy cái nhóm kia
hiện có đây không nhỉ nhỏ ma ở nhóm 32 có rồi 05 32
32 nhựa Hôm qua vừa nhắn tin mình sau A em nhắm mắt hay còn đâm nhỉ
ừ ừ
à à đã
hai ngày không biết là được họ đậu xanh
bạn Việt à anh mạnh Việt hôm qua hôm qua hôm kia
vừa nhắn tin mình mãi
a coma hai hôm nay hôm trước nhắn tin cho mình ở đâu vậy ạ
à à
em à ok ok có mấy nhóm kia chuẩn bị ngã bởi vì mình có thể hiểu có pha nhóm mà
kiểu họ không E63 hay 13 14 Đúng không mấy nhóm lại
mấy nhóm này có thể mà không có mặt là gọi đến tên nhóm mình luôn đấy Đây là
những mày cần cãi nhau của chuẩn bị trước đi đúng không
khi sex số bao nhiêu
Đức Hoàng
ừ ừ
ơi con có
anh ạ
Ừ ok em trà xanh thứ năm à ok
Ừ anh Trung Tôi sẽ đánh dấu lại một giàu Đúng là sửa thứ năm mà vẫn mất tích thì
thôi Không cho bảo vệ thật A1
à à
Chị đánh dấu đúng
05 32 alo alo 356 trước kia Sinh năm 65 ạ
phụ nữ hoàng là nhóm Sáu đúng không Đúng rồi à
ừ ừ
à à à à à à
anh em setelah em ạ
[âm nhạc]
à à
nên ra làm gì đâu đó cho các nhóm sau cũng chuẩn bị đi ngó 32
sĩ nữa bảo vệ buổi sau thì nó 13 ba ngày 14 này làm một này kiểu gì nhau một hôm
nay vẫn phải bảo vệ các bạn chuẩn bị nhé
à à ở nhóm 13 sắc có Đây đúng
À nhầm ba có 53 và nhóm ba có lấy không
ở nhóm 3A
anh nằm mơ có Xuân Hoàng
số 53 bạn kia Vợ bận à
ở ngã ba
đến với vẫn có người bỏ kê ở
nhóm 3 thì có không bỏ mặc tài bỏ
13 thì bận này tất cả đã Thế thì nhóm 14 và nhóm 1 thôi
ừ ừ ờ ờ
anh alo alo em Em nói đi ừ ừ
ừ ừ
các xe tăng đ Ừ em ấn chia sẻ màn hình đi à
à à cho nên thấy chưa ạ
cho anh anh thấy Anh Thơ
Ừ
rồi thì nếu Đây là nhóm sau
em tự chủ đề là lúc sau mới hàng á
à à vì
lý do trời tay này là vì nó trị của
[âm nhạc] nó chỉ không ngừng của công nghệ thông
tin truyền thông hiện nay á thì dài đang là một xuống mốt thời trang mới nói
chuyện anh ạ
ở Nam Định bán hàng online là bao nhiêu là kinh
điển của việc bán tán hạn trên 24A a Garena Em muốn
làm ở trang web kiến I love vì mấy ngày nay à
à à
các đối tượng khách hàng của em là có đàn
ông phụ nữ đứa trẻ trẻ em
tin mới lại trẻ nhỏ là có thể nhân viên quản lý
nhưng doanh nghiệp à
vị trí
lý tưởng của hệ thống thì mình sẽ có là khách vãng lai I
3 cách tra tài khoản như ra là tất cả tài khoản ạ
cô nhân viên bán hàng
là kiểu hết pin còn quản lý hệ thống số 30e à à
Chúc các bạn online thì sẽ có
ở những bộ đồ ghi lại Model đăng ký đăng nhập
xem sản phẩm Đợi tí nhất thì em ấn em ấn tìm kiếm các sản phẩm em bận ship F5 đi
để biến hành trình chiếu đi Nhìn nó rõ 00000 ở bên PowerPoint PowerPoint
sheet F5 bí ẩn ship S5
à à - phím siêu mỏng
ấn cái trình chiếu Powerpoint cpap 5A
Em bấm vào cái biểu tượng trình chiếu được thì em biết bấm
à à
ở đâu anh ạ à à a ly ở dưới á
chi tiết
ừ nóng ở cái nút biểu tượng trình chiếu ở
dưới góc phải màn hình phim hoạt hình F5 được F5 được
anh alo
à À rồi em em chia sẻ như là em chia sẻ đúng mỗi cái có thể hả Alo Alo
anh alo em anh alo alo alo khi anh tắt tiếng rồi
kìa à
ừ ừ Ừ anh mở tiếng mày nghỉ à
à à à à
à à anh em em ấn ở chọn chia sẻ màn hình mày
đúng thì như thế vừa rồi em Hình như là chỉ chọn chia sẻ mỗi cái mỗi ngày cửa sổ
này nên không được em em đổi lại chia sẻ màn hình
Ừ em ấn em Ấn lại vào cái bên em ít đi
anh ở đây cái kia mua xe nâng in High Screen mà Ừ hình như là bạn đã chia sẻ
cả màn hình rồi
anh alo alo
ăn thịt Mẹ đang run thì vậy ừ ừ
anh
alo alo alo alo alo em à
à à anh
alo mẹ nghe thấy anh không ạ hai a rồi em bấm bấm ship F5 đi
ship f5e
đi
hát phòng cũng được thôi Em bấm vào cái biểu tượng ở dưới
cùng bên tay phải đấy thôi
ờ ờ
à à
à à ừ ừ
ừ ừ
ừ ừ ừ ừ
bộ đồ em trình bày chơi Ok Ok
à à
anh ạ
ừ ừ
anh alo hình như là em tắt tiếng rồi
đấy Bên Thầy Âm Nhạc
Ừ cái này có tài khoản thì cũng tin
những tính năng của khách hàng của ai
có thêm à khi đăng nhập tài khoản đăng nhập shop
có đặt mua hàng chị đã thay đổi thông tin cá nhân
em có đánh giá sản phẩm có bình luận đánh giá sản phẩm và xem Hủy đơn hàng là
trung bình Em Tuyển nhân viên bán hàng thì có
mình có đăng nhập đăng xuất thay đổi mật khẩu quá nhân anh có xem trình đơn hàng
xem là thay đổi thì nhận đơn và quản lý sản phẩm là có xem chi tiết
thêm xóa sản phẩm ca nhạc
superman thì là tương tự như của khách hàng Ừ nhưng mà có thêm quản lý thì việc
đặt hàng là quản lý cấp dưới có xem xiếc
sửa sửa xóa lại thêm à
[âm nhạc]
ra nhận đây là sơ đồ tể của trẻ em
ở đây là sơ đồ cơ sở dữ liệu
300 Em phải trình bày cả hai cái đấy chứ không phải xe mỗi hình đâu nhỉ
bên A ừ ừ
à à ở bệnh nhân viên
nhân viên thị xã mỗi nhân viên sẽ rất nhiều đơn còn mỗi
hóa đơn sẽ được Tuyệt vời mỗi nhân viên khách hàng cũng vậy mỗi hết ở đơn sẽ
được gặp phải một hàng một cái hàng có thể tập đi được không
giúp được ở huyện
Quan hệ mới sản phẩm là ạ Vâng ạ
anh hóa đơn có nhiều sản phẩm hoặc là một phẩm có thể cho có chuyện gì hóa đơn
à à ở
nhà xúc nhà sản xuất thì có thể sản xuất làm ra nhiều sản phẩm với nhau
sản phẩm em có một nhà sản xuất thôi
khi trở lại về giới tính thì một sản phẩm có mà sản phẩm thì có một sạch và
xay lại một cái tính thôi còn một giới tính có thể là có một cái tính
là nhiều có nhiều là sản phẩm sản phẩm
ừ ừ ở
bên đây là em nói chuột à
Ý em nói là một bên là tên nhân viên ê số nhân viên là thể hiện ra các thông
tin của nhân viên em đi kèm với lại tình trạng Việt đơn Nói
nói cái ID của nhân viên
e27 với nhau Còn bên A à à
du lịch đơn hàng thì sẽ có là thông tin của bên đơn hàng là có thời
gian người người nhận thông tin người và thông tin của người đặt hàng sẽ ở trong
bảng người
Có người đặt hàng về có thông tin là id id tên giới tính thì sẽ nói với bản
ah cô đơn hàng đơn hàng
hình ảnh đó thì em có luôn một mảnh nhỏ là khi mua một
mẹo nhỏ là bạn quên mật khẩu của bên khách hàng thì sẽ nói ID của khách hàng
à
ừ ừ
Ở Đây là đơn hàng sản phẩm từ ADN thì là có bản trung gian ở Nhật Bản ngon đơn
hàng sản phẩm có ID sản phẩm và ID đơn hàng sẽ nói với
cách ID của bảng tướng ý ừ ừ
chi tiết sản phẩm thì sẽ có các sản phụ
thuộc thường có bản bình luận Anh em đánh giá của
khách hàng đối với sản phẩm thì sẽ cách lấy ID của sản phẩm và lấy ID của
khách hàng à a a
Bản thể loại mà giới tính của sản phẩm Ừ chị sẽ nói cái này ai đi cuộc
t&j bản sản phẩm sẽ có cái id của máy tính
sẽ lạc hướng hình
ảnh sản phẩm cuối cùng các bạn sản phẩm cuối cùng có 7 đối với mẹ sản xuất ở bên
ai đi à
ở nhà sản xuấ à
mini kia là admin lít à Âm Nhạc thì mình không nên bánh
Làm sao bỏ sự đi lại
tiếp theo có chứa axit là gì nhỉ
access là quyền truy cập Asus là cái quyền truy cập đúng không
để làm gì nữa ừ ừ
anh em để phân biệt giữa Apple Super admin à
Anh lại cứ tưởng nó là khóa cơ khóa tài khoản kiểu không không được axis mà
Không không được vào ấy đã phải đổi tên cái đoạn này ra là
nó nồi đến tiếp theo nha nối tiếp theo dõi City Story nghĩa là khóa thì phải
một cái đó là
restore elego quản lý lịch sử đơn Hà
a self-study cho nó lịch sự đến Hàn đúng không Dạ
đúng rồi ạ
Anh ở kia anh thấy à có một khóa chính là hóa đơn
ID hóa đơn à à
Ừ đúng Ừ cái bảng lịch sử lịch sử ấy hả Đúng
rồi em ở
bảng 7 bảng Hay quá
Hay quá trình chỉ có hai cụ và quả chính thôi chứ
không có được vào nhau với anh quá trên Ok mẹ là 11 nào với cô nào nhỉ
ở cột a Có ai đi của đơn hàng của cuộc ID của
nhân viên à tác dụng nó là gì đã sao em lại để hai
cột đấy là khóa chính
à à
Câu trả lời là con nào
ở nhà thờ ơ có tác dụng của nó là đẹp ở chung là
ừ ừ
những hình ảnh
hôm nay là bảo vệ thật đấy hôm nay bác thuyền bảo vệ như thế một cái à
vì
nó không có thể hiện được cái bát xong sẽ hiện
cái khác biệt của
Thôi cứ thể sau đây để để sau trả lời riêng đi các bạn thì lại nhá tiếp nhận
tiếp là
bảng is là gì nhỉ
làm bánh đơn này đơn hàng này đặt tên nó hơi khó hiểu những ao với tắt của từ gì
nhỉ à à à
anh
không Không ai làm thế đó rồi nói chung là bé bảng à
ở bảng đơn hàng đúng không ào qua đắt là bảng đơn hàng chi tiết
đúng không ạ ừ ừ
Ừ đúng đơn hàng chi tiết Ừ ok ko
em xem có gì họ lắm Em tao bảo xuống là cái bên Lịch sử Hóa
đơn là do em ơi Chỉ có cái ID là hoặc chính thôi
nhiều khi đó sau đó nha Hai cột Đấy cũng là quá trình nữa
cột cột và hóa đơn chi tiết thì phải hai cột
nó khóa chính mình mới đúng 11 hóa đơn đạt được nhiều sản phẩm mà
đúng không để cậu Lịch sử Hóa đơn vậy thôi thì
nữa cô lịch sử hóa đơn của lịch sử hóa đơn thì thì lại nếu em làm thế Ở lại say
một vì Đúng như bọn kia nó phải hai cột nó có chính mình mới đúng bởi vì Đúng là
một đơn thì chỉ có một tình trạng tại một thời điểm thôi Cái đấy thì đúng
Ừ nhưng mình mình phải lưu lại việc
admin nào thay đổi cái tình trạng Giả sử là nó đang đổi từ
đã hủy Thành đã duyệt chẳng hạn Nếu Nếu giả sử em cho phép làm điều đấy Còn nếu
mà em không cho phép làm điều đấy gì thì không sao
em Em hiểu ý anh không ý cho con gọi hiểm Cái này là bên thuyết
minh cũng không rõ ừ thì ở đây À thì ra là quan điểm của em muốn thế nào thôi
giả sử em muốn à khi khi mà order
em không nghe mà ở kia anh thấy là nó có thêm tình trạng làm mới mà tình trạng
mới tất cả lúc mà mới đặt thì thì đã lưu ở đây rồi đúng không và mới đặt thì nó
là luôn nhưng mà đi Ừ
mới đạt thì admin ID ở nun đúng không Thì Quốc than nó là gì nó ra luôn à
Vâng ạ Ừ Ừ Thế lúc đấy nó lại thành thừa đúng
không anh nghĩ thế thì hơi thừa ở đây nếu mà em giả sử của em chỉ có quy
ước đã duyệt với đã hủy thôi thì em có thể
Một Cột là khóa chính là cột ID và em thường ạ thời em chỉ cần lưu lại là ăn
mi nào lần cuối đã cập nhật cái đơn này là đỡ nhân là chị đơn thì cập nhật sao
đã hủy không thể đã diệt được thì ok Còn nếu mà em lưu lại theo cậu giả sử Giả sử
về sau đơn của em có nhiều tình trạng không phải mỗi Hủy Diệt nữa giờ sửa đang
ship này rồi đã hoàn thành này hay là đang liên hệ vân vân này thì đơn có rất
nhiều tình chạm vào lúc đấy Cứ mỗi lần tình trạng là mình là phải lưu lại lán
mi nào đã là người can thiệp vào cái đơn đấy thì phải có hai cột nó khóa chính
xe tải hiệu gì anh không
ở cái đoạn này có thể các bạn thấy con mới
nếu mà Bởi vì nếu mà làm lịch sử thì thường người ta lưu lại toàn bộ từ đầu
đến cuối phải lịch sử chứ không phải lưu lại lần cuối ấy đâu nếu mà lưu lại lần
cuối thì không cần ở tồn thêm một bảng Mình sẽ lưu lại thẳng vào trong cái bảng
ODA là được Ừ thế Đỡ phải tốn nên một bạn nữa
sau khi mà có một bảng trung gian thì mối quan hệ của nó luôn là một n1n tất
cả một hóa đơn sẽ được thay đổi nhiều lần thì mới tạo ra hàm bản trung gian
hiểu cho anh không còn 11 hóa đơn mà chỉ cập nhật Đúng một lần như em đang định
làm thì chỉ còn thêm một cột Nữa thêm hai phút nữa Ví dụ ở cột admin là
ID lúc nào để chống này hoặc một tình trạng đơn trong bảng order là được thế
kỷ thêm một cột nữa là cột khi nào mà được cập nhật
là ba cụt từ lại hôm bảo vệ thật nó tắt nhanh lắm không không kịp đâu các bạn cứ
giữ nguyên nhân và